في كلمه امام البرلمان الكندي قالت رئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبي ارسل ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي لن يقبل ابدا بان تهدد روسيا
امنه واضافت ان الاتحاد لن يقبل بان ترسل
قوه عسكريه لديها احلام امبراطوريه
دباباتها الى ما وراء الحدود الدوليه هذا
واكدت رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه ان دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي لن تقبل بهذا التهديد
لامن اوروبا ولاسس المجتمع الدولي مشدده
على وجوب ان تدفع روسيا ثمن جريمه عدوانها
على اوكرانيا قال المتحدث باسم الكريم
منسق معتبرا ان مدبريل عمل الارهابي
يريدون تشتيت الانتباه واكد ان التقارير
ليست غربيه فحسب بل تفوح منها رائحه
الجريمه الوحشيه على حد وصفه مشيرا الى ان
الكريم لا يفهم كيف يعتبر المسؤولون
الامريكيون حادثه خطي انابيب التيار
الشمالي عمل الارهابيا دون اجراء تحقيق
واضاف بسكوب ان روسيا لا تزال غير قادره
على الوصول لوثائق تحقيقات
السويد والدنمارك مؤكدا ان على الدول
المستثمره في نوردستيريم وكذلك الامم
المتحده ان تطلب تحقيقا سريعا وشفافا في
التفجير
من جانبها قالت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه ان لا
علاقه لكيف بتفكير خط نورد ستريم بدورها
اكدت الحكومه الالمانيه ان تحقيق المشتركه
مع الدنمارك والسويد بشان توفير مستمر ولم
يصل لنتيجه بعد وكذلك بل ذلك بعد ان تحدث
الصحيفه عن تقييم الاستخبارات الامريكيه
اشار الى ان مجموعه الاوكرانيه نفذت
الهجوم على خطوط العام الماضي كما اشارت
تقرير الا انه لم يثبت بعد ما اذا كان
رئيس الاوكراني على علم بالهجوم الذي قد
يكون نفد من مجموعه اوكرانيه
ياتي هذا مشاهدينا فيما شكك وزير الدفاع
الالماني
لاوكرانيا كانت وراء الهجمات على خطوط
وقال ان هذه العمليه ربما تكون مرفقه من
روسيا لالقاء اللوم على اوكرانيا وايجاد
مبرر للحرب وجار الى ان هناك احتمالات
اخرى لا تقل ترجيحا عن اتهام اوكرانيا
بالوقوف وراء هجمه
من يقف وراء تفجير خطي انابيب نور ستريم
صحيفه ديتسايت الالمانيه كشفت ان محققين
دوليين عثروا على القارب الذي استخدم
لتفخيخ انابيب نوت ستريم وان منفذي
العمليه فريق كوماندوس اوكراني
الحكومه الالمانيه اكدت ان التحقيق
المشترك مع الدنمارك والسويد بشان تفجير
نورت ستريم مستمر ولم يصل لنتيجه بعد
صحيفه كشفت عن تقييم للاستخبارات
الامريكيه اشار الى ان مجموعه اوكرانيه
نفذت الهجوم على خطوط
العام الماضي
التقرير الذي يتحدث عن تورط اوكرانيا
بالتفجير نوتس ريم يبرر طلب موسكو اجراء
تحقيق مستقل بهذا الشعب هذا ما قاله مندوب
روسيا الدائم لدى الامم المتحده فاسدين
من جانبها اعلنت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
انكياز غير متورطه على الاطلاق في
الاعتداء على خطي انابيب نوت 3 ولا
معلومات لديها عما حدث
[موسيقى]